aspiration it wasn't like i'm gonna go
i'm uh you know pro athlete you see the
rock i'm you know
playing miami dolphins and i'm gonna go
this right now okay i'm gonna go
do movies i'm to act i'm going to pursue
this like for you to say i'm going to go
fighting then i'm going to go comedy and
then eventually i want to be able to do
xyz that was not the case for you no i
just go and then if i enjoy it then i
just build the best team around me and
then try and have the most fun and
hopefully it works out got it so what's
next for you what do you want to do next
big project that excites you it'd be
literally the the thick boy network in
my own studio and we do several shows
out of there you know similar what you
guys have here we you know we do a
million shows out of there
um
it's funny you asked me that because uh
rob daredevic he was on the show and he
he was looking at things and he's like
so what's the plan he kept going what's
the plan i'm like dude quit [ __ ]
asking what the plan is
and then i made fun of him for it and he
kind of shut him down which is probably
not the smart thing to do because he's a
brilliant dude and then a week goes by
and goes hey i need to talk to you it's
been bothering me all week man you got
to have a plan you use can you uh
facetime tomorrow at four i'm like sure
dude so he facetimed me and he was just
you know he's a good mentor to have and
he's like you're 38 when i was 38 you're
the exact same as me man you're making
this much money you're doing this you
think everything's all good
i think like is it are you you know
you guys are independent
i mean you're with the big guys so yeah
i just think like you know when when you
when you
when you see this how much of it is um
the individual cast and division of who
they want to be how much of it is the
agent or the manager from ca saying hey
have you thought about this i think you
can be xyz i think you can be you know
that that that i wonder if that
conversation is are you pitching are you
getting pitched like what's the they've
pitched me on a number of uh auditions
for certain things
but it's just we're in a different world
now so it's like
let's say i get booked to do some movie
unless i'm [ __ ] the next batman or
something it doesn't make sense for me
to do vancouver for eight weeks miss my
kids
miss all the podcasts all the stand up
i'll make more money doing my owning my
own business doing all the other stuff
that i wouldn't be on this close to
saying make more money doing only fans
man oh man well you never know i'm gonna
say never you never know somehow
by the way this is exactly what they
don't want to hear no they don't want to
hear that what he just said because the
level of the level of uh desperation
they need people give me any job man
i'll take anything give me anything you
got me you need a 15 i mean my
agent at ca and the guys they won't mind
me saying this but we butt heads because
they only touch touring or if they you
know if there's an acting gig or they
you know they sold my special for me and
so
you eat what you kill for me i'm not
your traditional johnny depp where you
get 10 of everything i do the podcast
network and my shows completely you
don't have an overall deal
no not at all you negotiated that yeah
all that yeah so they don't touch
anything in my podcast they don't touch
it man i run that all myself
again different model that's the like
that's the completely fresh mod for them
i bet it is
what we learned from chas chat chaz
palmitary sat there told the story about
how he sold uh uh a bronx tale and it
was the most incredible story i've ever
heard in my life there's only two guys
in the history of hollywood did this him
and sylvester stallone long story short
dude is broke people that have watched
the podcast you know which podcast this
was broke
has a car that that's the bottom of it's
rusted out in the passenger seat doesn't
have a bottom he gets offered a hundred
grand for bronx tail but he can't play
the lead he can't play sonny turns it
down 200 grand turns it down 500 turns
it down cold million and if you if you
say no we're dropping you as a client
turns it down no damn says i'm going to
be sunny ends up signing the deal with
robert de niro he's sunny his whole
career goes oh damn you know analyze
this everything else for but the ability
to say no nobody's saying no no yeah but
for every one story like that during
that time there are tens uh yeah of
thousands like you know bruce
springsteen hey your voice sucks you
know but you got good lyrics you could
be a good writer but you're not a
for every one you know the rocky story
he sold his dog you know everybody's
heard those stories but the business
model has changed for good and bad
because there's no
there's like no criteria to start your
own podcast there's no criteria for you
you know to get famous off youtube and
then try and do stand up because you can
sell tickets they're going to book you
no matter if you're the worst comic in
the world so it's it's a you know it's a
blessing and a curse so the industry
still tries to kind of we talked about a
little bit off here they still like look
down their nose a little bit like
youtube and they're like you know but at
the same time i think it's because
it takes the power away from them like
it's an internet i'm trying to figure it
out though it's an international casting
call i mean you're out here talking to
the whole world and then the world can
decide whether like you're not it's not
somebody in an ivory tower in downtown
lake green lighting you the world is
green lighting yeah no yeah hollywood
doesn't have the power anymore right
this guy can do this this guy can't they
really don't i mean you saw what ricky
gervais said at the at the the
awards yeah the oscars we got up he says
listen you guys may well just throw in
the towel and give all the you know
words to netflix
[Laughter]
but he's right i mean that was ricky
gervais every time he gives this message
there's depth in his thinking that guy
is a brilliant guy yeah i love him
his speech i hope they booked this guy
again i really hope that i don't know if
they're going to do it or they're scared
to never my god so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]